Colombia Venezuela continúan estrechando
sus lazos luego de que este jueves en
Caracas los ministros de defensa de
ambos países acordarán Un aumento de las
tropas en los pasos informales de la
frontera El objetivo combatir a los
grupos criminales que operan a lo largo
de los 2200 kilómetros compartidos sin
especificar plazos ni la cantidad de
unidades ambos resaltaron la decisión de
combatir a estas organizaciones
le transmitía al Señor ministro padrino
este propósito que es una decisión del
presidente Gustavo Petro
de enfrentar las finanzas criminales
con la mayor contundencia posible como
lo venimos haciendo en Colombia y se
viene haciendo en Venezuela también
confirmaron que Caracas devolverá tres
embarcaciones retenidas de 2020 tras ser
encontradas a la deriva y sin
tripulación en una Ribera del río
Orinoco un gesto que para los ministros
resalta las mejoras en las relaciones
bilaterales pero hablando en privado
estábamos admirados de lo rápido que
hemos avanzado y de cómo hemos sanado
aquellas heridas para avanzar para
construir nuestro futuro nuestro nuestro
bienestar colectivo nacional desde la
Asunción de Gustavo Petro como
presidente colombiano las relaciones con
Venezuela se han reactivado incluyendo
la reapertura de fronteras terrestres y
el patrocinio de reuniones para
solucionar la crisis política venezolana
[Aplausos]